why would someone who loves movies and
writing quit the film business you know
it's interesting we get into an industry
that seems so romantic to other people
and they'll say that people have said
that to me oh my god how could you have
been working in movies and leave almost
like we're beholden to that and now
we're not allowed to go have you know a
new career
and even though there are many aspects
of movies that i loved and continue to
love
there were a lot of
areas that were challenging
like distribution for your movie
financing your movie and you'd spend
years putting together a film writing it
finding the team finding the money you
put a labor of love into it and then
nobody would buy it and nobody would see
it and that to me just was
a little bit too heartbreaking for
longer than 20 years
and so you made a feature film was it at
19. i made 11 films and i started at 21
and the first couple ones calista
flockhart who ended up becoming ally
mcbeal she was in a film that we were
sort of an associate producer on which
is kind of how you get started when
you're young in in i don't know if it's
the same now but back in the day that's
that's what it was and what that
basically meant was is we found
something for free basically
because that's how you operated then
because everybody was on such a
shoestring and then after that you know
now you say oh i've been an associate
producer right so then you get an
opportunity to be an associate producer
on another film and then next thing you
know it's just you start to learn more
and then you're able to start taking on
producer producer credits
did anyone sit you down in the beginning
and say
you know this is a this is a get ready
to wait type of a business and people
will tell you all sorts of stuff and
then you'll never hear from them again
or did you have to learn that there were
no mentors
we had women in film which i didn't find
i found was a little uh like
non-inclusive
um and so you'd volunt i did a couple
volunteering
gigs there and then i was like i don't
know i don't know it just it it
as a woman in a man's business and
especially as a young woman
you didn't really want to let people
know that you didn't know
so there was a lot of kind of fumbling
around in the dark
to
you learned from your mistakes basically
so when you make one mistake you're like
well let's not make that mistake again
when you worked in hollywood producer
writer production coordinator did you
have any other jobs no i didn't i in the
very beginning i was a temp
so when i was in new york city i had
some pretty crazy temp jobs and
um we were making this movie we were
kind of getting ready to make this movie
at the time and i was really stoked
because i think it wasn't like lehman
brothers or like one of the like
i don't remember what the bank was that
the guy went and sold everything and
crashed the whole bank i was there like
working for the person i think i i try
to i can't remember exactly but i look
back and i'm like oh my god i think i
reported to his office but they had
these like massive
xerox machines
so we needed what was called um pages
and we also needed the schedule printed
on like blue paper and green paper and
pink paper and we had no money this is
awful but this is what you would do to
make movies is i would sneak into the
copy room and when no one was looking my
damn job i'd whip out like 400 copies of
you know a colored schedule for the
for the production
okay
and no one found out no i was pretty
wily okay and i did my job i did my job
i got my job done but it was a little
bit too in the in the movie business
that i felt there was this like
justification
that as i grew into more integrity in my
life and especially the business i'm in
now my company a story inside i had to
look back and there were a lot of things
that you were kind of expected to do or
thought you had to do
to for the art
and i look back now and i think that was
one of them it's like i was stealing
if you think about it that wasn't my
paper they were not paying me for that
job and we would do other things like
you know
fill water bottles that we had gotten we
bought maybe one
poland spring bottle
and then we'd fill it with a hose for
the rest of the production but we
wouldn't tell anybody you know just
you know and then you'd be like well it
saves money and it's for the art and i i
just over time you start to think
i don't want to
try to unpay people and rip people off
anymore it just doesn't feel like that's
what that art should be
sure sure and and was that later on
after you left the film industry that
you sort of had that
sort of making amends type
exactly i mean
i think because it was ever you know
like everybody did it there was just not
i mean we were pretty you know we were
pretty sneaky in new york we made some
pretty we did some pretty sneaky things
i think i remember there was a story we
didn't do anything dangerous like we
didn't put anybody's lives at risk and i
remember there was that film where they
were like they didn't have a permit and
they were shooting on the railroad
tracks and a couple people died wasn't
that here in california recently and i
was just thinking
oh no we didn't cross that line yeah
we worked in some pretty scary places we
didn't cross that line interesting
and then you left and then i left
voluntarily or the economy it was kind
of like i had a baby in 2005. we left
los angeles to uh you know maybe have a
little bit more of like a suburban life
which almost killed me um it was a
little too suburban for me it was like i
went from echo park in la which is
really rough and like artists over to
suburban san jose
and just there wasn't really any access
to any film anymore um i tried to keep
writing screenplays
um i did write one in 2010
and that was the last one
and so contrary to what people say that
you can be anywhere and be writing a
script did you feel that to be true no
i think you have to be in los angeles to
take the meetings
meet the people
collaborate with others on their
projects
right place right time know the
attorneys know the agents
i i don't think you can do it anywhere
else
have people fought you on that yeah i
mean i haven't really talked to anybody
about it in a while um
but i think there's those few
movies that are made in other places
that originate from other places you
know they're made in florida and they
break through but the breakthrough is
typically through
agents or people that are in la that
like might see the film and suggest it
for a festival or they're involved in
sundance um i think there's some
component that has to be in los angeles
but you did write a script while you
were in the bay area yeah i did i did
and those people had contacted me from
my contacts in l.a
so they weren't people i met in the bay
area
when you told people in the bay area
that you were in the film industry
previously or that you were writing a
script what was their reaction
i don't really think i told anybody oh
you didn't know okay a closet
screenwriter okay i like it i don't
think they they like they had nothing to
do with the film business they were like
they would have been like okay okay i
see you right
like your mom's group you know
they're talking about kids i see okay so
it never came up yeah meanwhile i was
writing this like her you know horrific
torture script so i don't think it would
have been like a great conversation sure
you wouldn't be invited to the birthday
exactly they'd be like look out watch
out for her
you